Oh world. It's the Raj. In this episode,
we're going to build a stock price
prediction graph using [inaudible] in 40
lines of python. Have you ever
wanted to get rich quick, sir?
My models are very profitable.
I always retrain them to prevent
over fitting three times a week.
Those are rookie numbers in this ragged.
Really? How often do you retrain?
I'm going to have to work workout and
then once, right if your lunch. Oh,
the stock market allows
you to buy and sell units.
The ownership in a company which we call
stocks. If the company's profits go up,
you own some of those profits. If they
go down, you lose profits with them.
It's as simple as that.
So if you were to buy stocks and
the right company at the right time,
you can become rich overnight.
Is there something we could do to predict
future stock prices given a Dataset of
past prices?
Machine learning.
This sounds like a data science problems,
but according to the
efficient market hypothesis,
the stock market is
random and unpredictable,
but major financial firms like JP Morgan
and Goldman Sachs having been hiring
quantitative traders for years to build
predictive models on past market data
and you can be sure that if these firms
do have profitable models for trading,
they are not going to share it with us.
Come at me Wall Street,
they have no incentive to think about all
the features we could incorporate into
a financial model. Sentiment analysis
on company opinions, past stock prices,
sales growth, dividends, all the profits.
Warren be missed for hating on bitcoin.
Changes in stock prices are not
completely random but very close to it.
Good traders will use predictive models
as a tool when deciding where to invest
and we're going to build three different
predictive models that predict the
prices of apple stock.
Then plot them all on a graph to compare
their results are steps we'll be doing
staller dependencies, collect our Dataset,
right our script and analyze our graph.
These are our four dependencies.
CSB will allow us to read data from the
CSV file of stock prices that we later
download. Num Py will let
us perform calculations on
our data side, can't learn.
We'll let us build a predictive
model and map talk live.
We'll let us plot our data points with
our models on a graph for us to analyze.
Let's collect our data set.
We want to list of stock prices from the
past 30 days and we can get this data
easily from Google finance.
As you can see,
it'd be much higher if they didn't
miss the boat on Ai. Next step,
write our script.
Our for dependencies are here at the
top and we'll use the given names to
reference them throughout our code.
One thing to note about map plot line
is that since it's a graphical library,
it'll depend on a graphical backend
and there are several options.
If it doesn't want apply to graph
on your machine for some reason,
just use the switch backend option and
try out a few different possible backends.
All right, let's start
hacking on our script. First,
let's initialize to empty lists,
dates and prices will then
write a function called get
data that will fill them
both with the relevant data.
We'll call it get data and its argument
will be the name of our stock prices CSB
file.
We'll use the width as blocked to open
our file and assign it to the CSV file
variable.
The open statement.
We'll extract the contents of our CSV
fall to read it, hence the our parameter.
Next we'll want to create
a file reader variable,
which the CSV module will create for
us using the reader method with our CSV
file as the perimeter.
This will allow us to iterate over every
row in our CSV file and we can return a
string for each line.
Using the next method.
We'll call the next method
first to skip the first row,
since it's just column names.
Now for each row in our CSV file reader,
we'll add both the date and price
values to our respective lists.
The upenn function will allow us to
add an item to the end of our list.
We only want the day of the
month, so we'll say get that
first column in our row,
which is that the index zero and use
the split function to remove the dashes
between each of those three values.
Then get that first value in the list,
which is the day.
We'll wrap that using the into keyword
to convert the day to an integer for
prices will append that list
as well with the opening price,
which is in the next column of our row
and convert that to a float to be more
precise in our later calculations.
Okay. Not that precise.
Well place the return statement at
the end to finish our with block.
Let's move on to our second and last
helper function called predict price.
To build our predictive model and graphic,
well first use num Pi to format
our list into an end by one matrix.
The three parameters will be the list
we want to reshape the new shape,
which will be a one dimensional array.
The size of our dates list,
and finally the order of elements.
Let's create three models.
Each of them will be a type
of support vector machine.
A support vector machine
is a linear separator.
It takes data that's already classified
and tries to predict a set of
unclassified data, so if we only had two
data classes, it would look like this.
It would be the line such
that the distances from the
closest points in each of
the two groups would be farthest away.
When we add a new data point to our graph,
depending on which side of the line it is,
we could classify it
accordingly with the label.
The right now we're not predicting a
class label, so we don't need to classify.
Instead we're predicting
the next value in a series,
which means we want to use regression.
SVMS can be used for regression as well.
The support vector regression is a type
of Svm that uses this space between data
points as a margin of error
and predicts the most likely.
Next point in a Dataset,
let's create our first model,
a linear support vector regression.
We'll use the spr module we imported
from psychic learn to create it and it's
going to take three parameters.
The kernel, which is a type of Svm.
Then our penalty parameter.
See of the error term we want to things
when using an SVR aligned with the
largest minimum margin and align that
correctly separates as many instances as
possible,
but we can't always have boats.
See determines how much we want
the ladder. Our next SVR is Paula.
No meal in math folklore.
The no free lunch theorem states
that there are no guarantees for one
optimization to work better than
the other, so we'll try both. Also,
if you work at Google, you actually do
get free lunch, so take that. Finally,
we'll create one more SVR
using a radial basis function.
RBF defined similarity to be the
Euclidean distance between two inputs.
If both are right on top of each other,
then that similarity is one.
If too far it's a zero.
Our gamma defines how far too far it
is and let's fit or train each of our
models on our date and price. Using
the fit method, it's time to create.
Our graft will plot the initial data
points as black dots with the data label
and plot each of our models as well.
We'll use the predict method
of the SVR object in psychic.
Learn using the dates
matrix as our parameter.
Each will be a different color and
we'll give them a distinct label.
We can set the x axis and the y axis
accordingly and we'll add a title and a
legend.
The show function.
We'll display it on the screen and want
to return the predictions from each of
our models.
Now we can call our get data method on
our CSV and create a variable to store
our predicted price given our
dates and prices for this date.
Well printout results for each
of our models to command line.
Let's analyze our graph.
We can see that each of our models shows
up in our graph and that the RBF model
seems to fit our data the best so we can
use its prediction in command line to
stack dead presidents.
So to break it down,
the efficient market hypothesis states
that the data needed to set the prices
for tomorrow.
Stocks only come from tomorrow,
but well tuned machine learning models
can give us predictions that are slightly
better than random if we use
the right data and support.
Vector machines are a type of ml model
that can be used for both classification
and regression to predict novel
data points. Intergraph graph.
The winner of the coding challenge
from last week's video is victor.
See Ronna Vic,
you're created a system that recommends
artists to users using the last dot.
Fm Music Dataset that asks of the week,
and the runner up is Kevin Nelson.
He demoed his own recommender algorithm.
The challenge for this video is to
create a financial model to predict stock
prices with a neural network using both
price history and sentiment analysis.
As features details are in
the code, read me, post your,
get humbling in the comments, and I'll
announce the winner. In the next video,
please subscribe for more
programming videos. And for now,
I've got to predict snapchat's IPO price,
so thanks for watching.